[Music]
See right now I need you. I need you
somewhere now. You up now. I see you. I
get you. Take care now. Slow
down. I miss you. Come here now. It's
yours now. Keep it. I'll hold on until
now. I need you right now. Once I leave
you, I'm sure you now. If I get you, I'm
slowly breaking
down. And know it's hard to say, but I
wish you were here. Oh, it's hard to
leave you when I get you everywhere. All
this time I'm thinking we could never be
a pain. Oh, no. I don't need you, but I
miss you. And oh, it's hard to see you,
but I wish
you. Oh, it's hard to leave you when I
get you everywhere. All this time I'm
thinking I'm strong enough to sink it.
Oh no, I don't need you. But I miss
you. You love me. He loves me. He holds
me tight, then lets me go. He love me.
He loves me. He holds me tight, then
lets me go. So when you leave me, we
always lose connection. It's getting
messy. I feel your
affection. Don't loosen your grip. Got a
hold on me now forever. Let's get back
together. Take it so far away.
I don't wait. I want you to take me up
and down around and around
again. And know it's hard to say, but I
wish you were here. Oh, it's hard to
leave you when I get you everywhere. All
this time I'm thinking we could never be
there. Oh, no. I don't need you, but I
miss you. And always hard to see you
when I wish you were right here. Always
hard to leave you when I get you
everywhere. All this time I'm thinking
I'm strong enough to see it. Oh no, I
don't need you. But I miss
you. He love me now. He loves me. He
holds me tight then lets me go. He love
me. He loves me. He holds me tight then
lets me go. He loves me now. He loves
me. He holds me tight then lets me go.
He love me not. He loves me. He hold me
tight then lets me go. You got to say
that you're sorry. At the end of the
night wake up in the morning
everything's all right. At the end of
the story you're holding me tight. I
don't need to worry in my head and
always hard to see you
without you and I you everywhere all
this time I'm thinking I'm strong enough
to sing. Oh, no. I don't need you, but I
miss you. Come here.
[Music]
Hey friends, I hope you enjoyed that
flow session. I really dig that
graffiti. It's right around the corner
from my uh apartment and I've been
meaning to go spend there for quite some
time. So, I'm glad I finally did. Uh, by
the way, if you dug the uh poi that I
was using in this video, those are Orb
Poi Pros from Ultra Poi. You can go pick
those up at the link that I have down in
the description. And you can get 10% off
on your own set of them when you use the
code drexfactor with a zero instead of
an O at checkout. Once again, that is
Drexfactor with a zero instead of an O.
Thank you so much to Ultraoy for
sponsoring this video and giving me a
reason to go out and get my flow on
every month. Cheers. Uh, speaking of
thank yous though, uh, I also owe thanks
to the friends of the channel. Big
thanks to Dark Monk, Fire Mecca,
Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyroer, Light
Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible. You
can learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video. And a special
thanks to the non-B business friend of
the channel that is Becca Bakon. Thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. And
finally, this video and all the videos
on this channel would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on
Patreon. In particular, I'd love to give
a shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now. You all
rock. Thank you so much for watching. Uh
if you want to see more flow sessions of
mine, I will go ahead and include a link
to a playlist of them down in the
description as well as up on screen.
Have a good one. Uh make sure to get out
and flow yourselves today and I'll see
you with a new video real soon. Take
care now. Peace.